I gave a talk at the first Ted in 1984
that was two hours long and it had five
predictions in it that more or less all
came true and people called them
predictions but they really weren't
predictions they were extrapolations the
reason I talked for two hours is not
because I was Fidel Castro and I was
giving a rally it's because I had 15
years of research stored up was about to
open the Media Lab and it was real easy
to talk about what we were going to do
and some of it even seemed old hat even
though in retrospect people thought oh
this is amazingly predictive 30 years
later they say make a prediction as if I
had made predictions the first time
which I hadn't so this here actually did
make a prediction and it is in the
prediction category in the sense that
it's not an extrapolation of work I've
been doing for 15 years but it's part of
work that some of my colleagues have
started at the Media Lab which is really
looking at the brain not just mapping
the brain but how do you interact with
the brain pretty directly and almost
everybody who's done that has done it
from the outside you know with sticking
pins and needles or you know EEG or M eg
or other ways and the key to my
prediction is best way to interact with
the brain is from the inside from the
bloodstream because if you inject tiny
robots into the bloodstream they can get
very close to all the cells and nerves
and things in your brain really close so
if you want to input information or read
information you do it through the
bloodstream so by extension and this is
you know by its predictions because it's
by extension you could
theory load Shakespeare into your
bloodstream and as the little robots get
to the various parts of the brain and
they deposit little pieces of
Shakespeare or little pieces of French
if you want to learn how to speak French
so in theory you can ingest information
and that was my prediction I won't be
around to see whether it's true but you
know like many of these predictions it
doesn't have to be true as long as it
gets people thinking and there are
people thinking about this and looking
at it quite seriously and I think it's
it's a area in in sort of synthetic
biology and and sort of the interface
between biology and silicon that is
really what the future is about the
digital world today is like plastics
were 25 years ago it's important field
but kind of over digital world is like
plastics and the biotech world is the is
the next phase